this was actually one of the first
hoverboard factory they could produce
maybe 15,000 hoverboards a month on
animals I pushed them up in the first
page bestseller actually and you guys
remember not just Amazon us we're
talking about Amazon Germany and a
little of France Italy and the UK meet
Howard ty the man who claims credit for
turning this anonymous Chinese
hoverboard factory into a successful
global business I guess that's what they
called me over because I teach them how
to sell on Amazon his job manipulate
product listings in Amazon to boost his
client sales for the someone treated tea
saying that goes out at me pulled a gun
home choose your vehicle if he's I'm
falling out so much for do a tell him to
ginger go no no Jude he's one of a
number of self-proclaimed experts who
are sometimes called
the gurus so there's different gurus for
different things most of them they do
have their own traits their own
expertise if you are an Amazon user you
may have noticed that sometimes it's
really hard to figure out which products
you should buy sometimes they all look
the same
there are half a billion products all in
one site all vying for your attention
and the reality is the vast majority of
buyers would only click somewhere at the
very top of the list to get one of those
spots some sellers are ready to do
anything fake reviews artificial sales
and even bribes all of which violate
Amazon rules Howard ties advertised
illicit tactics to potential clients and
charges thousands of dollars for his
consulting but says he does it mainly to
defend sellers who have come under
attack did I just get myself in trouble
or anything I did I do anything back yet
The Wall Street Journal investigated for
months around the world and we came to
China's tech and manufacturing hub to
know more about the shadowy tactics used
by online sellers here to beat their
rivals
okay we found that many sellers choose a
radical approach to become one of the
first listings you see when you search
for a product they take down their
competitors so here is our logistics
center as you can see we have here like
a small assembly line Amazon
entrepreneur mayor sim he moved from
Israel to China 11 years ago he says he
has been a target of several attacks
holiday seasons two years ago just
before Christmas before Cyber Monday and
Black Friday I wake up in the morning
one day I look at my computer and I see
zero sales the reason was my main
products were suspended if a competitor
want to kill you just have to leave few
fake reviews to your product every day
you wake up the first thing you do is
checking your reviews you wanted to know
if you're still in the business or not
insiders say one reason attacks are so
common is that they're extremely easy to
pull off the manipulators exploit
Amazon's automated system returning a
product and flagging it as dangerous or
fake can trigger an immediate suspension
they will purchase our products and then
they will return it claiming that the
product is not as described by returning
the product they will also increase the
return rate which will make Amazon
suspend our product page so then what do
you do is your product just finished in
some cases yeah you cannot come back
from this kind of attack amazon says it
is put in place of fistic ated systems
to monitor attacks that genuine sellers
are promptly allowed to list again
however sim he explains it can take
weeks to be back online it's a jungle it
happens all the time
for me it can cost like tens of
thousands US dollars a year
another way sellers are violating
Amazon's rules to try to boost their
products is by writing fake reviews
because the more positive reviews
sellers have the higher up their
products will appear in listings making
customers more likely to buy when you
look at the reviews for this product you
can see that it's very popular but
there's almost something too perfect
about it when you dig down a look into
the reviews you realize that while this
product is a pair of headphones the
reviews described and screen protector
it looks like a very clumsy piece of
manipulation in the case of these
headphones we emailed the seller but he
didn't reply so if you are an average
buyer how can you spot fake reviews from
China it's easy
according to Howard he sat down in our
studio to explain it's just really about
how it sounds like as long as it sounds
like it's from natively from the US and
has some kind of saying and and doesn't
have too much broken English you know
then it should be a good good review
anything short I would think it's really
fake it's awesome kind of sounds pretty
fake to me the question is how do people
actually generate thousands of allegedly
fake reviews every day during our
investigation we found that specialized
websites control thousands of buyer
accounts and use these to sell fake
reviews to sellers based in China or
anywhere else in them if amazon
discovers that a seller is using illicit
tactics amazon will ban that account
however many Chinese sellers have
multiple selling accounts so if they get
banned from one they'll just switch over
to another and if that one gets banned
they'll just make even more
[Music]
on Amazon in general the more vendor
sells the higher is ranking so to
artificially boost sales companies have
commissioned third parties to buy their
products some professionals told us they
even sent empty boxes to random us
addresses and claimed genuine
transactions it's particularly
widespread among producers of cheap
generic products like those on sale in
this market here we are at one of gen
gen the largest wholesale markets I mean
it's just incredible what a range of
electronics and how cheap all of this is
what we see here is that they're selling
tons of generic electronic products
they're basically indistinguishable from
one to the other it's your cell phone
charger versus another cell phone
charger and because these are all
virtually indistinguishable whoever can
corner the market by making sure that
their product rises to the top of the
listings is going to get all the sales
so that gives sellers a huge incentive
to manipulate the market and drive their
products to the top
and finally let's talk about corruption
which of course is totally against the
rules
during the course of our reporting we
discovered that Amazon is investigating
certain of its own employees to
determine whether they are accepting
bribes to give advantages to sellers
according to people familiar with or
involved in these transactions sellers
pay bribes ranging from $80 to $2,000 to
Amazon employees in China to delete
negative reviews restore banned sellers
accounts and obtain restricted Amazon
data that will help them boot sales so
what does Amazon say about all of us
they told us they are constantly
monitoring the website for suspicious
activity and that users trying to abuse
it system make up a tiny fraction of
activity on its site Amazon also uses
sophisticated technologies like machine
learning to combat bad users they also
pursue civil and criminal penalties but
people like mr. ty saying that so long
as Amazon will be governed by algorithms
and artificial intelligence
there will be humans out there to trick
the machines you get this kind of
problem where automation and will will
lead to a lot of loopholes because their
system right now is very vulnerable and
they don't do enough and many sellers
are getting hurt
[Music]